[Music]
hello and welcome to the weekly climate
show a look at what's got my pulse
racing or blood boiling in recent days
and this show is all heat and dust also
known as weather and weathering with
maybe a casual glance at a sweaty week
in westminster now amongst the many
downsides of climate change one i feel
acutely right now is how it saps the
simple pleasure of a hot summer's day my
relaxed basking and daytime drinking is
disrupted by thoughts of planetary peril
and now personal peril as the first
national emergency for extreme heat has
been declared for early next week with
the uk health security agency saying the
risks of illness or death apply to
normally fit and healthy people well
just before warming further to this
theme a quick nod to viewers in the west
of scotland i know you've had it
miserable wet and cold while reading
headlines about heat waves but you are
the exception and it's not just much of
the uk where the mercury is rising
much of the northern hemisphere is
enduring unusual heat in america 50
million people are living with heat
alerts china has seen record
temperatures reached in shanghai and
here in europe we've seen wildfires and
health warnings as the thermometers pass
40 degrees celsius and here in the
studio i've got a friend to talk about
all this skies science correspondent
thomas moore thomas is this the new
normal it's certainly what climate
predictions have suggested would happen
for quite some time and it's now coming
to pass in every country around the
world we're seeing temperatures climb
but in some areas it's climbing much
faster and that is the problem that
you're getting in much more intense heat
waves in the decades to come and are we
also seeing more blocky weather if you
like yeah and that's the really
interesting thing tom is that the jet
stream is slowing down so when you do
get some where the patterns
coming to halt over areas it's not only
hotter but it's hotter for longer and if
the ground starts to dry out that water
vapor would normally help to cool the
air but that's gone and that does
magnify the heat yeah i hear this a lot
from farmers that spells the weather are
now lasting for lasting for weeks rather
than days well while you and i are stuck
in the studio some of our fellow
correspondents have been out feeling the
heat first hand and our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter has
been in portugal
this has been an absolutely punishing
heat wave for portugal and perhaps most
obvious of course in the wildfires
ripping through the north and center of
the country and now in the south too
climate change is driving the conditions
that are making those experiences worse
for the people who live in those
communities
underneath it all you've got this
incredible heat this prolonged period of
heat which is making it very difficult
for firefighters to battle those fires
but it's also incredibly dry
around 96
of this country is under drought
conditions and what that means is that
the forests in those hills where the
wildfires have been doing the most
damage
our tinder dry acting as kindling
helping these fires really to relight as
soon as the firefighters get one blaze
under control
another pops up fire season in portugal
has extended over the years and local
residents told me that it's definitely
getting worse
so what now
climate change is impacting portugal and
it's really the heat they are worried
about because it's
not just dangerous in terms of wildfires
and public health impacts heat's also
really expensive because there's the
cost of the emergency response but also
people are way less productive in
significant heat events understandably
so
so i interviewed a senior politician the
secretary of state for home affairs
patricia gaspar
who told me
that the country has to shift its
mindset to accept a new reality and to
think really radically about altering
the way this country lives its life
particularly in the high summer months
she was talking about making sure that
big events don't happen in forested
rural areas
she was discussing the possibility of
thinking about altering co-working hours
in the hot summer months to help people
avoid the hottest part of the day
these are big shifts that mimic what
cities and communities in the global
south have been doing for a long time
finding ways to work around
the impact of heat
and the chief climate scientist at the
country's national weather service said
that this country must adapt because the
forecasts in climate science are getting
worse and his main concern is that
there's going to be a smaller and
smaller gap between these extreme events
and unless there's adaptation it's going
to be harder and harder for this country
to recover
as hannah said climate change is
beginning to change the pattern of
people's lives in portugal a country
which like us could once rely on the
neighboring atlantic ocean to shield
them from extreme heat
over in germany they're experiencing
drought right now with the rhine running
low ironically on the anniversary of
terrible floods which killed more than
180 people our europe correspondent
siobhan robbins takes up the story from
a wine cellar
so you join me in a wine cellar and i'm
down here because this is in the r
valley one of the areas which was
devastated last year in the catastrophic
floods that germany experienced and i've
come down because vineyards and wine
were one of the industries badly
affected and we can speak to peter now
and peter just tell me how bad was the
flooding here it was a total catastrophe
inside of this cellar completely flooded
i see you maybe you can i will show you
this on the wall so the water stands
between the number two and number three
and we are lost by night here in this
cellar in the tanks and barrets 40 000
liters of wine and also 20 000 bottles
inside are completely destroyed by night
wow and and you've got these bottles
here if you just show us something these
are bottles that were
impacted in the flood covered in mud and
i understand you're now
auctioning them off now yes so we are
also looking in the future and we will
be innovated and uh so we make an nft as
this once and there's auction also and
we are looking for this one what's
happening with these flood wines these
are completely everyone is flood wine
and every bottle looks different like
the other ones and it's a kind of art
also in a kind of remember at the
catastrophe and all the money here will
go to help the region rebuild
it's a difficult time for germany though
isn't it because the war in ukraine has
put severe pressure on your energy yet
at the same time all of us here in
europe are living through changing
climate there's heat waves there's
floods
for you how difficult is it is does
climate still take a lead or are you
more focused on getting energy
so uh for us here in this cellar and the
wineries so let's not be implanted we
are also changes we are changes to wood
power and restarting completely because
everything was destroyed here the
heaters was destroyed everything and so
and yeah in time we don't need gas
inside this this cellar peter thank you
and it's an interesting
tug of war here in germany like many
places around the world because of the
pressure on energy some people are
questioning is climate still as
important should it take a back foot
should we be using coal at the moment to
plug the gap at the moment the majority
of public is still saying that climate
is important
but we're seeing every single day
the impact of climate change on our
lives
and thomas i gather you've been out tree
hugging in guildford looking at
something that isn't necessarily a
solution but a cool adaptation to our
sweltering cities yes very much so trees
are nature's air conditioners and they
are that low-tech solution for what is a
very big problem that problem is the
urban heat island effect and that's when
concrete jungles become extra hot we
know from studies in london and
manchester the centers of them can be 10
degrees warmer than the surrounding
countryside but even provincial towns as
small as guildford can have that effect
too and we went down to the university
of surrey and took a look at some of
their data on monday and you can see two
sensors there
one in the built-up area and one in
parkland and just watch what happens as
the temperatures climb through the
morning early afternoon there is a seven
degree difference between them
temperatures absolutely stunning
temperatures then cool through the
afternoon and into the evening but even
at midnight there is a three degree
temperature difference between them and
that is why people in cities really do
find it very difficult to sleep but also
people are exposed to the health effects
of heat you mentioned the effect of
concrete and hard surfaces but expand on
that a bit and also is there a kind of
solution to it yeah so we had a go with
a thermal camera just to illustrate the
problem and you can see that uh hard
surfaces asphalt concrete brick steel
that absorbs the sun's energy and then
radiates it back long into the night but
nature trees grassland that's much
cooler and not only are trees casting
shade and it's cool blue in in these
pictures but it's also
evaporating water the trees use some of
the sun's energy to give off water keeps
them cool but also cools the surrounding
air and that's really important in the
years to come people are saying we
should plant more trees in cities
because that will provide not only the
shade but the cooling effect not just
for beauty and habitat but for keeping
us cool too now away from the cities i
noticed that noticed forestry england
encouraging us all to go down to the
woods to chill it's usually as thomas
says a few degrees cooler under the
canopy
now we've got time for a little any
other business in the contest to be the
new prime minister the candidates are
finally being asked about climate change
and we are seeing some rowing back from
the firm 2050 net zero pledge we'll have
more on this when it's down to two
candidates next week but thomas you've
been looking at a policy that was once
claimed to be a measure to help the
fight against global warming that's now
coming under a major assault very much
so and this is to do with biofuels
that's crops which are grown to be added
to petrol and diesel that we stick in
our cars and the original idea had been
that that would be carbon neutral that
you they would the crops would absorb
carbon from the atmosphere and then when
you burn them off in in a car they just
give it back and it should be net zero
but it's not and that has been a a big
controversy for a long time but there is
one group now saying that because there
is a big impact on food security with
the war in ukraine a lot of biofuel
crops are grown there now if you stop
this requirement for sticking biofuels
in cars those crops could be used for
people but in a sense as i say this is a
controversy that's being raged for a
while because land is finite it's being
asked to do more and more isn't it tom
as you well know no i was going to say
that's such a big issue with biofuels
because they really do gobble up a lot
of acreage and you've got to put all
that diesel in there and fertilizer and
all those things which do have climate
change impacts
for sure i mean it's not just growing
food it's it's absorbing carbon is
growing biofuels and you know if the
population is going to grow by 2 billion
people by 2050 that's a lot more land
that's going to be needed just for food
thomas thanks very much we could chat on
for a while of course we do have
extensive coverage of the heatwave
online for that and all our other
climate coverage just head to our
website or the sky news app
well later we'll be answering some of
your questions i love this question from
earl who asked me on youtube
my electricity bill is supposed to be
100 renewable and the production cost of
those renewables has been going down
so how can they blame rising gas prices
for my bill going up well your answer
when we come back
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show now
before the break erl asked us why his
bills are still going up despite having
a renewables tariff when it's fossil
fuel prices that are rocketing well for
an answer let's hear from our business
correspondent helen ann smith
hi all thanks for that question uh the
key reason for that is it's not your
energy provider that distributes your
energy that still comes
from the national grid and crucially
it's physically impossible the way the
national grid is set up for any one
particular house to be supplied with
just one energy source uh ofgem like to
use the analogy of a smoothie uh so this
the smoothie of different energy sources
still supplies each house and the more
people who buy renewable tariffs the
more that the renewable part of that
smoothie would go up but there is still
natural gas in their
nuclear and other things
and of course that means that your
tariff is still exposed to the gas price
in that way the other reason is because
of the way that companies purchase
renewable energy so when you sign up to
your tariff uh your renewable tariff
your energy company has likely uh
possibly invested in renewable energy uh
to about the same kilowatts that it
would take to power your house that's
kind of how the trade-off works and
unfortunately the cost of that
investment is also pretty exposed uh to
the energy market more broadly so the
cost of your company paying for that
renewable energy has likely also gone up
because of the gas price going up and
that unfortunately uh gets passed on to
you i hope that goes some way to
answering your question
a revelation there that perhaps those
100 renewable tariffs aren't always
quite what they seem
now as you may know by now we love a
climate change solution on this show
many of them high tech like last week's
one involving graphene so a drum roll
please for today's contender
[Music]
a rock basil a rock with some famous
outcrops this is stafford with its
distinctive basalt columns and this is
my effort at an album cover there with
my boys but that's enough holiday snaps
it's time for your two favorite lessons
combined geography and chemistry
basalt has been capturing carbon for
millennia in a process known as
weathering
carbon dioxide mixes with rainwater in
the air to form a weak acid and when
that falls on rocks like basalt it
reacts
combining co2 with chemicals in the rock
to make carbonate and bicarbonate
molecules these then wash off the
mountain into the soil where it helps to
make them more fertile and into the
ocean where it makes seawater less
acidic
wherever it ends up the carbon is
captured for millions of years and now
when co2 removal is urgent we've
discovered a way to accelerate the
process called enhanced weathering
a basalt is found in pockets across much
of the north and west of the country
including
this quarry in fife
basalt is a foundation stone of our
economy 39 million tons are dug from
britain each year used in everything
from roads to aircraft engines
here big boulders are shifted then
crushed into smaller chunks ready for
different customers
but there are leftovers that carbon
capture company undo have their eye on
so this is an aggregate which is
produced to make concrete with so
concrete goes into building foundations
and building constructions throughout
the united kingdom
over this side we have a 14 to 6 mil
product which is used to make asphalt so
that goes into tarmac to make roads with
the by-product the material here
is what we're interested in this is the
undo fine granule material and as you
can see it comes out
in enormous quantities until you got
here this would have been a waste
product yes it was yes and now we're
fine to be used for it
that use is getting paid in carbon
credits for shifting it and spreading it
on farmland
what are you digging out to show me that
i'm wanting to show you the particle
size the increased surface area in in
this material is where we're wanting it
to hit and capture the carbon what do
you think when you see a huge pile like
this the potential of it what do i think
i think win win win never mind building
another rocket to the moon it's here
it's around us it's under our feet and
we should be getting on with it
jennifer's excitement is shared by many
scientists a recent report from
sheffield university said spreading rock
dust would be a huge step to meeting our
net zero targets and used globally could
absorb five percent of the world's co2
emissions
when we're using this dust
we are capturing the carbon for hundreds
of thousands of years this is a simple
way right under our feet um that we
should be realizing now we don't have to
build massive plants and we don't have
to build a massive infrastructure it's
here it's nature's energy and we should
be using it at the moment you've got
quarrying transport and spreading all of
which use fossil fuels that's got to
undermine this idea a little bit hasn't
it we do have to take that in account so
we know we're capturing x amount of
carbon we have to subtract five percent
of that um
for the trucking operation we've got 95
we've captured it but keeping that
figure low means loads only go to farms
within 50 miles of the quarry and this
load of dust has come about 40 miles
to farm here
it's then spread across 450 acres where
alongside helping the climate the
minerals help the crops too
what's going to be growing out of this
field in a few months uh winter wheat
will follow this not that there's
much to see at the moment what are you
hoping spreading this stuff will do for
the crop that grows here
well hopefully and
improve its health
therefore we won't have to use as many
fungicides fertilizers and what about
the climate benefit does that mean
anything to you as well that's of
interest to me but that's secondary to
me growing my crop
a waste material that could fight
climate change and grow more food no
wonder it's being nicknamed magic dust
well who would have thought that the
simple elements of water
and rock could make such a difference to
our climate
sorry let's almost have to clean that up
later but we do still have time to
answer a couple of the questions that
you've been sending in
and james asked via our app whenever
temperature is mentioned it's always
hottest since records began when did
records begin given the earth is over 4
billion years old what were temperatures
like a thousand years ago 10 000 years
ago or 100 000 years ago
well james the oldest continuous
temperature record began in 1659 it's
called the central england temperature
data series but there's not really
enough data before the year 1880 for
scientists to estimate the average
temperature for the planet
for the thousands of years before then
scientists use proxy measures like these
ice cores drilling into old ice and
analyzing trapped air bubbles for
evidence of past weather the oldest
continuous ice cores in antarctica
stretch back 800 000 years and the rise
in temperature corresponds to a rise in
co2 in the atmosphere
and now a question from rishi and
presumably not that one what measures
can be put in place in the summer to
prevent people from getting seriously
ill or dying and will new uk houses have
to be built differently to be cooler
radhika kosler is one of the world's
leading experts on cooling
key ways to adapt to extreme heat one
make sure that everyone stays hydrated
and stays out of the sun
second to make sure that when cooling
appliances are purchased whether they
are fans or whether they are air
conditioners to make sure that they are
at the highest level of energy
efficiency this is really important to
make sure that the forms of cooling that
are used are sustainable the third is to
focus on the building stock we really
can't get away from buildings and the
built environment as being a key
solution to this extreme heat so making
sure that our buildings are well
insulated that they provide for shading
that they provide for ventilation and
then fourth at the city level to make
sure that we have enough spaces such as
green spaces such as water bodies
such as shaded regions that provide
relief from the extreme heat for those
that are outdoors
and if you want your questions answered
you can scan the qr code here or go to
any of our social media accounts where
you can add questions in the comments
and of course we can look at some of
your questions in more detail victoria
taylor asked us about the impact that
air travel has on climate change now
that is a very good question and one
that we'll be looking at in greater
detail
next week and just a little bit of good
news before we go a massive offshore
development has been just announced by
germany which not only will have huge
turbines in the sea but it will use some
of the power to create hydrogen from
seawater a process called electrolysis
which is a really big hope for a lot of
renewable technology that's it for this
week do stay cool in a very very hot
week to come and look forward to seeing
you again next weekend
[Music]